Please welcome Zach Braff and Donald Faison.
(audience clap and cheer)
Hi Drew
Hi everybody
Oh my God
Hi Drew
(audience clap and cheer)
Oh I'm so happy to see you both.
I have like, I've known you and loved you for so long,
by the way, Donald, all my girls and I
are watching right now is "Clueless".
So, nice to see you
I love that.
That makes my day right there Drew, yeah (laughs)
When my wife...
When I speak to my wife later and she's...
If I get on her nerves in any way, I'll be like
well you know, Drew watches "Clueless" so it's all good
(laughter)
And
You know what
I know you want to talk to Zach
I'll let you do it
No, no, quite the opposite
I have so much to talk to you about you
both of you.
Okay, when I first moved to Los Angeles actually
Breckin Meyer, Paul Rudd and Alicia
took me out to Jones and we met you that night.
You and Johnny from "The Karate Kid"
the bad guy from " The Karate Kid"
and I just (Zach laughs)
it's one of the highlights
it was my birthday.
It's one of the highlights of my life.
Wait a minute
I had a hit movie coming up
I met you and I got...
Well I met you through Breckin Meyer.
Breckin was...
And every time I've seen you since
and I've always been like
I know Breckin
(laughter)
He was...
Breckin Meyer a.k.a Travis Birkenstock
was like my first boyfriend in like grade school.
Wow, wow.
Yeah, I love Breckin.
Did you just say Johnny a.k.a William Zabka
from "Karate Kid" and "Cobra Kai", was there?
Absolutely one of my favorite shows ever
It's the best
When Paul was so excited
it's the best right? Thank you.
Get Zach on board
(Donald laughs)
Well also, I'm sure that everybody is talking about
a "Scrubs" reboot and a "Scrubs" comeback
and a "Scrubs" movie I know it's been discussed,
and it dovetails perfectly into your podcast Zach
I mean, I love you as a writer and a film maker,
and "Cobra Kai" did such an interesting job
like re-checking back in.
Do you ever think of
how you would get back into "Scrubs" creatively
not the of to spill the beans here but do you ruminate?
Yeah, but you know with Donald and I doing this podcast
we never thought it would be this fun.
It was kind of a...
It started right before COVID
and it's just exploded
I mean it's taken off like neither one of us
could ever imagine,
and that's just been thrilling.
And of course the podcast has made us
really want to do more together
and there's talk of doing some sort of movie or something.
Well, chemistry is king. I really believe that
and you guys have it.
Your real life friendship translates.
Your chemistry, do you think that that's the hook for people
and is it what makes it so fun for you guys?
Yes, the truth is that we get along so well.
We just crack each other up
and I think we don't really need the podcast
like our parents will listen
maybe a few hardcore fans
and then little by little we'll be doing it through iHeart
which has zillions of podcasts,
and the guy from iHeart calls us he's like
"You have no idea what's happening across the globe.
This has become, it's iHeart's number one podcast
across the globe."
And they were like, "You guys are the level of success.
Do you want to do like a tour?"
I was like Oh my God,
you mean we could live the rock star life
and get a tour bus and go around?
They're like "Absolutely."
So when COVID is over we're going to tour Europe
and do the show live in font of people.
Guess what, you're already set up with all the merch.
I just got this
so you're halfway there with your tour.
And Drew, we've sent you a onesie too
that I really want you to wear at some point.
Yes, I'm going to throw it on for sure
I just got it.
I was texting Drew and I said I sent you a onesie
and I expect to see you in that onesie.
And what's hilarious is I was like
I wonder if he's joking or not
and I was like okay
No he wasn't
And I was like either way, yeah, of course.
All right, but guess what
who's gonna have this on when we come back from commercial.
Yeah, right.
For real?
Maybe, we'll see
(upbeat music)